that's how much I paid yes to share
about your in an apartment today we'll
be playing true or false about the cost
of living around the world do you know
anything about it I mean I've lived in
Asia for a bit but I'm not really sure
sort of like going to summer camp going
up we travel I've spent like a month in
Costa Rica six weeks living in Peru and
then like traveled around Europe true or
false
the United States it's the tenth most
populated country in the world what are
the other nine I thought it was like
seven I think we're like four or five
you seemed confident I feel like there's
like maybe six sure false in Nigeria a
one-bedroom apartment in a city centre
costs upwards of $2,000 per month I'm
gonna say true I feel like this one's
trying to trick me okay yeah that seems
like pretty crazy that's like Oh a price
maybe it's true I mean I think it's
false nervous in the state of California
United States one can expect to pay on
average 14 10 for a 1020 square foot
apartment
you think it's too low I feel like
that's not a big one I don't think it's
big is this with utilities I think I
don't know how big screwer Falls the
most populated country in the world is
China
sure that's true yeah okay I was in
Nigeria the average salary is the
equivalent of 1280 7.87 US dollars per
Mille yeah some places in Asia or like
that I'm not sure if I'm gonna say false
maybe true or false in Russia the
average salary as of 2019 is typically
higher than 3000 USD per month I have no
idea
I'm gonna go in the wind and say trip
months I think that I don't know why in
Brazil rent for a 900 square foot
apartment varies anywhere from five
hundred twenty-eight to 852 US dollars I
feel like it varies more than that
though is a huge country so yeah it is
it's pretty it's pretty thick yeah
really I don't think that's that much
for nine hundred square feet that was
true oh I'm getting everything wrong in
Indonesia a one-bedroom apartment in the
city center would cost upwards of $900 a
month the USD true I think this is true
I took a class where we talked about the
capital of Indonesia I'm forgetting it
now yes Jakarta thank you that was false
so a lot cheaper wait yeah okay Wow in
Bangladesh a one-bedroom apartment in
the city center is about 130 1.17
dollars per month I think it's less than
that I think it's true it's a very exact
numbers true because I would be similar
to Indonesia baby
true or false in Mexico a simple decent
meal at a busy neighborhood restaurant
or food court costs about $5 true yeah I
think that sounds about right
I think it's lower because yeah that's
like I agree it's like street food like
that's always cheap no matter where you
go okay nobody a one-bedroom apartment
in the city center in Pakistan is a
Cleveland of ninety seven point seven
seven US dollars per month I think that
that's true because it's a specific yeah
yeah nine eight seven five seven seven
y-yes dollars is like a good deal yes
cool true or false in Mexico one could
expect to pay around twelve hundred US
dollars for a furnished two-bedroom home
per month I'm gonna go a trip both cuz
that's like here I think it might be
less than that yeah we think it would be
less except that it's furnished so I
wouldn't make it that's about right
that's how much I pay people living my
house and that's my individual Wow
true or false a two-bed one-bath
apartment in China would typically cost
around 4,500 gonna be a month which is
about five hundred and eighty seven
point five US dollars plus another three
hundred I mean D for utilities one of us
is right I know in China like the rent
would be pretty different depending on
whether you're in its city or not I
think that's reasonable
- okay I think I only got like one right
that was really hard
I just think here is pretty expensive
yeah and I realized I do not know that
much about living expenses and square
feet
[Music]